Probably the most important consideration in cache design is the
trade off between speed and capacity. To help understand the impact
of this trade off, I'd like to visualize requests from the
CPU to Main Memory like this, where the orange lines represent
the requests to the CPU. We would like the cache hit
rate to be high and the speed to be fast. These
goals, however, are somewhat contradictory. We can have a small but
fast cache and just accept that this would have a low
hit rate, being only able to intercept quickly a few of
the requests from the CPU. Or we could have a large
cache, but this would be slow there. Either because the physical
limitations like the speed of light, or because of the high cost
of fast hardware. So we intercept more requests from the CPU.
But, we aren't able to return them as quickly. What is
the right trade off? Well, it's hard to say. But, fortunately
we don't have to make just one choice. We can trade off
side versus speed multiple times at various levels within
something called the cache hierarchy. What is not in
the CPU registers, we look for in an L1
cache. What's not in an L1 cache, we look
in the L2 cache. A multicore processors, there might
be even a third level of cache. What's not
there, finally we look for in main memory. Even
main memory, however, we can think of as a
cache for what is on disk. Or we can also think
about maybe main memory as a cache for what's on the file
system. Notice here that the top is smaller, faster and costlier
per byte. And as we go down the hierarchy, we get things
that are bigger, slower and cheaper per byte. And if we
do a good job of keeping the data that we're going to
access next in the higher levels of the hierarchy. That is, if
we can keep our hit rates high, then making at the speed
of the top part of the pyramid that has the capacity in
the overall cost per byte of the lower end of the pyramid.